hi guys it's over at again and back with
another episode of the tutorial series
and in this episode I'm gonna do the
path work now this is something which is
quite boring and time-consuming so I'm
probably going to split this up into
multiple episodes and they're not going
to be quite as entertaining I guess but
I hope that I can just give some basic
tips all the way through and at least
keep them like I don't know keep the
video somewhat serious and not too
boring
I always start when it comes to path
works I always start off with the paths
themselves and then start off with the
borders around them just because it's
easier if you do that the path covers
first so I'm just gonna do some path
covers on the sides of these parts right
here now this is just going to be a side
walk and it's just for multiple reasons
but I think the main reason is probably
just because it looks good now this is a
this is an easy way to make your paths
look pretty good without actually having
to add too much to it
sidewalk sauce is always something that
looks pretty nice
now I already see a problem over here
because this is this parts there's some
weird
terraforming stuff and this is not a
conforming path set so for this part I'm
probably going to get rid of the
sidewalks altogether because it's really
hard to do sidewalks on path yeah I'm
positive that go up to a hill or
something like that so I'm just gonna
not do any any path covers over there
there are some path cover sets like
Ralphie's sets and some other sets that
I know most of them are in the foliage
section because they're conforming but
I'm just not going to do that right now
because I do want to keep the same basic
path Koho all the way through otherwise
it's going to be very inconsistent so
I'm gonna open up again I'm gonna open
Costa Jose pathway extensions it's the
same setup I use Twitter Q and I just
think that it looks pretty good okay and
I can already see that over here it's
starting to do that weird thing and you
can't remove it so I'm gonna have to
terraform that later on to remove it
but I can add some path work over here
now I'm just gonna actually a better
idea is to start off with the curves you
can start off with these squares to make
the general layout but the best idea is
to start off with the curves so like
this I'm gonna use a 4 x 4 over here and
if you do that
you can have to use a 3 x 3 getting back
and if you use a 3 x 3 over here you
learn best way to go is to use a 2 x 2
at the back and for these diagonals
I do want to keep everything around and
smooth exit just looks good so I'm gonna
use these diagonals and when I use these
diagonals I always like to space them 1
and 1/2 tile apart so for example I'm
not going to place the other one right
over here but I'm going to move it over
tile over here so then the space between
this is pretty much the same as the
horizontal space so let's check it's
what's at this as well and then you just
need to add the diagonals and then what
I wait I messed that one up
sorry okay and then at the diagonals and
then in the middle I usually what you
can do is actually take these half ones
and just fill them up but if you've got
a very small curve like this I always
just use quarters all the way through
and the reason why I'm doing these weird
path works alright the rollercoaster is
because the setting of course is in a
theme park so if you if you have a theme
park you're most likely going to have
quite a lot of path work around the
roller-coaster also a rollercoaster
you can I kind of consider it part of
the scenery I mean there are some people
like like yeah I know that I do it I
would just look at rollercoasters you
know and those people are like you know
I'm not gonna ride it or I will ride it
but I want something cool to look at
like path works around a rollercoaster
is always a great idea because a
rollercoaster is pretty much part of
that theming because you want it to look
good
you want the people to actually see what
the roller coaster looks like okay so
now I am going to take these diagonal to
straight pieces again and just like that
okay now I can probably act like a small
boardwalk or something like that over
there and I'll see about that but before
I do that because this is a path that
uses the in-game textures for the path
itself I'm going to make this straight
because otherwise it's not really going
to work yeah and just like that okay
let's check if everything is good all
right now I can continue doing this
boardwalk thing it's not really a
boardwalk but whatever it's sir this is
one this is one of those paths that now
I pretty much just there to have a nice
look at the coaster over the lake and
I'm just gonna expand this wait no now
I'm not sure whether I'm going to have a
sidewalk on this side as well because I
know that I sometimes abuse my sidewalks
but what parks don't usually have
sidewalks everywhere and like some paths
have sidewalks some of the big paths
main parts of sidewalks but not every
thing has sidewalks and I think I'm just
going to keep the sidewalks to wherever
the rollercoaster is located and I'm
going to use them on these sides but not
on this on this side because that's
probably yeah that's kind of sidewalk
overkill okay now I'm gonna take some
diagonals again to fill in these things
it's always bits yeah annoying when you
need to fill in all these little diagnol
and quarter tile pieces but yeah it does
make the set very flexible and that's
one of the reasons why I like this set
so much and I'm just gonna fill these in
so I can use the half path cover just to
do all this
okay that is great now this section is
pretty much done now I'm just going to
have to figure out what I want to do
with this sidewalk I probably want to
remove this and to remove that that path
cover that I cannot remove I'm just
going to slightly move the grant like
that now you can remove it and then take
this smoothing tool actually smooth it
it's a bit more and it's all good again
okay so I'm going to open this at once
again because I want to see I can like
had a smooth ending to this sidewalk
transitions when it comes to paths are
pretty hard to pull off but they are
pretty important if you want your parts
to look good so I'm probably just going
to end this sidewalk with a pointy
straight two diagonal section yeah let's
see oh wait it's already intersecting
over here isn't it okay no that's that's
still good and let's see if what I can
do with this yeah okay that's actually
that's not that bad that's a pretty good
ending to a sidewalk okay I'll just I'll
just do that and I'm going to fit to
fill these things in again and as you
can see the diagonal parts even though
they're diagonal they're just about as
wide as the straight parts because you
have that extra of tile space in between
the diagonals okay now I'm going to
continued using these path covers on
this little hilly area so once again I'm
going to start off with the curves
because that's generally the best idea
just gonna let this run around the track
over here maybe take a little more
distance mmm yeah this is probably
better and again at three times three
gets back
it could be a little bit closer actually
let's see that's probably a bit too
close
I mean paths paths can't be too close to
the roller coaster because that's going
to get dangerous and you'd have to add
coaster nets to protect the [ __ ] but
that's quite a hassle and there aren't
any coaster nets for curves yet um okay
she's gonna use some diagonals over here
again you can also use these diagonals
to use to make large curves like five
times five curves that no-scent has you
can just make them yourself with
diagonals I guess and I'm just going to
count from here just to see where this
thing is going to end let's see I do
want it to connect to this point though
so I'm probably going to end it over
here yeah okay that should be good let's
check it though add some diagonals and
yeah that's good okay then
and if you're doing what I am doing and
you start off with diagonal you start
off with a straight piece going this
direction and you make it into a ninety
degree curve then you're always going to
have to use this quarter piece I squirt
a diagonal piece okay and now I'm gonna
fill in this curve as well because I
don't like the sight of seeing that
weird unfinished curve and just gonna
take these quarters
I'm just gonna fill this in with Cuates
as well because that's probably a
time-saving you don't want to switch to
another object just to place one one
like 1/2 thing when you can just place a
couple of quarter tiles okay now I'm
gonna extend this and I'm probably going
to add step no way I'm not going to add
stairs and Inc stairs on a main pathway
is a bad idea because obviously you've
got people in wheelchairs and stuff like
that and you do want you to be
wheelchair compatible and stuff like
that so I'm just gonna smooth it up
quite a lot though and let's see you
know that should be good not gonna
smooth this out because I I do want kind
of a cliff side over here plus it's it's
very close to the roller coaster over
here so smoothing this out would either
cause the roller-coaster to like to
screw up the supports or it will make
this hill very weird and steep so I
think this is just about good you know
that's pretty good and I'm gonna do the
whatever you call that the hillside path
copper thing I'm not even sure what
you'd call that but I'm just gonna keep
adding these yeah it should be good and
then later on I'm gonna use one of the
wall sets to make a either stone or
wooden wall over here just to make that
all look nice and just add some foliage
to that and hopefully it's going to look
good okay let's see I need the b1 no
that's going to cut the terraforming
pretty sure this should work though
let's see I don't want the terraforming
to be sticking out but no this is this
is perfect okay I'm gonna keep it that
this is gonna be their border I'm gonna
do the the inside border later on but
first I want to get a general idea of
where I want to have that wall
okay use another b1 oops
and the insight one oh it's hard to see
with the blue faces but still I always
like to keep the grid on because in any
many other cases it comes in pretty
handy okay then no mmm I might let it
run run that curve but I can also just
add a two times two curve I mean that's
going to be a bit big but it might work
you know that's pretty good and I do
need to erase this though because
otherwise there'll be a gap yeah good
and use the same terraforming good now I
get the path set again baths and
terraforming is not a great combination
no but it does look pretty good okay I
think that's a pretty nice shape now I
do see that I used the wrong texture
over here though okay that's good and
gonna use a one x one on the inside
because I use a two x two on the outside
and again this is going to be a b1 add
half a tile and same goes over here and
half a title and then it should match up
let's see okay that's all good all I
still need to do is fill in those gaps
and then I'm pretty much done at this
point you know that looks pretty good
okay and quarter one and a quarter
diagonal and then I think we're pretty
much done at this point and that is I
guess enough to fill an episode with so
just a short episode about some general
sidewalk stuff when it comes to making
parts and you can already see that paths
work is somewhat getting together and as
soon as you add railings and borders and
cool past essentials it's going to be
it's going to look a bit a lot better so
in the next episode I'm going to cover
the wall for this parts and I don't know
what else I'm going to do I'll just see
that then so till then